non si sono visti ma che pro ha
grandissima ricky è stato però mostra
fare questa volta dal nonno omonimo la
scorsa volta da non capire se non
l'avete vi faro vederlo perché ci siamo
divertiti tanti i suoi loro frogger igor
a te la nonna in scooter che si sistema
mai avute anche questa volta il nonno ci
seguirà con lo scooter non lordo eccolo
qua guardate lo vedete altre tre denti e
gli manca una cappa è sembra molto
arrabbiato sempre non sono un bel mi
sono incazzato per portarci fortuna te
non mi seguite ancora si integra mandate
seguirmi nomeni territorio
mettetevi comodi pure di bloccarne gli
outfit di oggi è tutto rosa come sono
vestita oggi come il corno da unicorno
siamo pronti video vi farete volte si
straccerà vitale e questo li ha
allora si è scritto in un nonno e il tuo
sito
la sua moglie quindi cerchiamo di
scappare quindi fortuna moglie la non
eccessiva e lui non le cui siamo già
scappati ok il tappeto che si è
arruolato c'è scritto che il nonno sta
accumulando spazzatura nella sua casa
quindi dobbiamo trovare un buco per
scappare
ok ho salvato era un po alto il volume
questa è la da allora dobbiamo trovare
una spazzatura che hai capito sabbie
mobili e quindi dobbiamo cercare dove
non cercare la giustizia uscita ha
passato qualche parte no no no non si
sono rimasto incastrato forse nella
sedia della sedia
no nella poltrona volevo dire no non c'è
niente quadra questa via d'uscita
io sto controllando a ok che sono
riuscito a passare deve prova andare
vicino alla poltrona dove è seduto il
nonno
ok e poi ho fatto io ho fatto un giro
della poltrona e poi mi sono fermato 19
era di programma tv il passaggio aiuto
di un'altra volta finito il fuoco c'è
scritto il nonno lasciato porre gli
accesi quindi stai attento dove metti i
piedi attento a non essere bolli per la
padella almeno non c'è il nonno che
vuole cucinarsi questa volta perché
l'altra volta la nonna volevate vero
biscotti noti avvicinare alla torta
anche se so che branca
porta pure il cioccolato guardare ogni
volta che c è qualcosa di mangiare la
pasta affettati
sì mi ha aspettato il coltello per dire
ma io ancora non si sono sfracellato non
si corre dolci non può stare qua sotto
pure il corno ok diciamo che bisogna
andare pure qua qua ci sono le stoviglie
con operai che carine a testa al
coltello non puoi saltare sopra dove ci
sono parti 5 guardiamo dove siamo
se devo saltare su queste basi su queste
palline i nomi sopra e delle lettere
sopra che cosa vuol dire miliardo ma si
vedono i numeri non le lettere ma
andiamo siamo qui c'è scritto sembra che
questo sia un vicolo cieco guardati
intorno per trovare una porta segreta
lavoro segreta allora traccia di una che
non è nascosto ma qui siamo passata c'è
qualcosa ma vediamo chi riesce a
trovarla prima la bordata che gli
occhiali brigate ma forse dobbiamo
spostare questo vediamo niente tutti a
questa porta nascosta assad si è
divertente però non la trama riuscito
trovando o sono solo caduta
c'è un indizio niente qui non ci pare il
caso
ho cliccato sui libri e timbri passaggio
malissimo
andiamo rito stiamo dentro alle
profondità della terra quindi cerchiamo
di uscire prima che su di noi questione
umano di uno scheletro qualcuno è
rimasto nella lava quindi qua il
pavimento è come no non mi sono
sfracellato neanche una volta 10 azzurro
crede io non gli può sapere poi ci
potete credere che vita è ancora non si
è sfracellato com'è possibile stai
diventando troppo grassi non mi fare i
propri complimenti perché adesso vi
sposate allora attraverso l'ultimo tutto
qua c'è il labirinto allora tu vai
dritto io vedo qualche io ho sempre
paura di perderlo forse qua e ti vedo ti
ci sono riuscita ok cerchiamo di evitare
questo lato pragelato per la prima volta
per noi ma ci credo che tutti se ne sono
già andati a tre quattro volte
allora di novara la portata dove io no
questa è chiusa in un livello 11 ha
preferito gara al tie è stato più
difficile perché hanno messo anche i
libri adesso è un fatto vai stiamo
diventando brasile oppure quei profumi
più facile attenta i tuoi passi perché
il pavimento e lava che cos'è questo
rumore che chiede sei riuscito a
superare il brutto ma stato impossibile
vita e vi aspetto bravo
eccomi andiamo non vedo l'ora di
scoprire se anche il nonno tra il motor
attenzione fotoelettrica non sarà facile
l'orologio a cucù escono fuori gli
uccellini che prevederà no
ma devi avere pazienza
1 lavoro ok poi numero 14 no ho un
brutto presentimento finiremo nella non
nella loro no contraddetti o no il nonno
faceva i lavoretti prima di impazzire e
quindi tipo falegname ci sono i
cacciabili hanno riferito di questi
orologi a cucù di nuovo partito che fa
venire adesso suggerito dai non soltanto
sui bulloni che sulle viti no no no
no aspetta ma sono aumentati i denti
ecco vitale allora c'è scritto siamo
intrappolati dentro la bocca speriamo
che il nonno non russi no io so già come
andrà a finire tra provate a indovinare
voi lo sapete vero sapete come questa
volta è un po diverso in genere è cosa
sono queste le budella ma solo voglio
sapere in genere vediamo le cose che ha
mangiato vediamo qua siamo nelle vene no
no sta rimediando tutte le volte che non
sono venuto prima ora è un po diverso
qua perché ci sono le vene
chissà se andremo nello stomaco lo
stesso definito vitale funzionato ok ci
sei riuscito a dargli sono a milano
[Musica]
ci siamo avvicinati un po troppo no non
dovessimo farlo 33 a 30 piano piano si
ce l'abbiamo fatta noi ce l'hai fatta
una ragione
l'ultimo pasto del nonno è anche il
nonno maggio senza masticare perché ci
sono intere dai non farti distrarre dal
cibo di falerone
mi sa che siamo nella tua mano c'è
scritto asteriti ha scritto uno stage un
livello che non voglio nominare perché
sappiamo benissimo che questo sarà molto
difficile
il trucco e saltare in continuazione dai
no non ci credo ce l'ho fatta non si
voleva tenere per sé verso 4 58 di volo
in genere evitare vuole se ce l'ho fatto
anch'io a meno male non abbiamo non ci
credo che ci siamo riusciti e siamo
diventati bravi oppure queste skype room
è facile vediamo dove il greggio dopo
che collezionare il badge haven e
dimenticati dunque lo hanno messo forse
nascosto da qualche dice ma non ci
apriamo si può saltare qua voglio il
bene vediamo che succede
sono finita nel giardino abbiano lines
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite